grab your ouija boards and watch out for
falling elevators because we have
episode 3 of lovecraft country
and it has whatever the hell this is
there is a lot to talk about in this
episode including
new theories on where the show is headed
what christina is up to
and what lies beyond that hidden tunnel
but before we begin
make sure to like and subscribe so
you'll be notified as soon as i come out
with a new video
let's all go to church somewhere i
haven't been since 1955 either here we
see letty crying watching hippolyta and
what is assumed is george's funeral even
though there's no casket to be found
there's a strange voice over here which
i originally thought was letty's mother
however it's pulled directly from nike's
2017
be true ad campaign so go ahead lay
fly the title of this episode is holy
ghost one of three elements of the holy
trinity the other two being the father
and the son
which could easily be substituted for
the mother and the daughter since the
other ghosts we see in this episode
aren't in any way related to religion
the holy ghost the episode title
is referring to is the one that haunts
letty more than anything
her mother we get this title screen
which tells us what the episode is about
but the two important things to note
here are the three missing people never
to be seen again and the words
pioneering is dangerous as we'll find
out at the end of the episode
these three missing people are the three
white supremacists who broke into
letty's home but were brutally killed by
the home's ghosts
pioneering here is a reference to letty
staking her claim in an all-white
neighborhood
as we'll find out damn is it dangerous
the events of episode 3 take place
three weeks after the funeral of george
who tragically lost his life last
episode after being shot by christina's
father
samuel rather than tell hippolyta and
dee that their father was killed by a
group of wizards
atticus letty and montrose tell them he
was shot by that racist
sheriff in episode 1 a lie which causes
friction between
atticus and his father letty has
received a surprise inheritance from her
mother allowing her to purchase this
giant haunted mansion
in the predominantly white affluent
neighborhood in the north side of
chicago what letty doesn't know
is that this money isn't from her mother
at all it's from christina who wants her
in that house
as we'll find out later this house has a
mysterious connection to the events of
episodes 1 and 2. one which will have
serious implications for
episodes to come letty shows her sister
ruby around and if you look closely you
can make out some science equipment and
books hinting at the previous
homeowner's profession
a disgraced physicist named hiram
epstein who was fired for performing
experiments on humans
hippolyta is getting ready for church
tearing out pieces of brahms stoker's
dracula
george's favorite book perhaps she's
feeling guilty for letting george go on
the trip which got him
killed since she offered in episode 1 to
go in his
place or maybe she knows more than she's
letting on about what really happened to
george
regardless she can't let go of him even
though she rips out pages she ends up
buying a new copy later in the episode
perhaps the most telling example of her
still holding on to george is when she
almost pours
two cups of coffees at breakfast one for
her and one for her now non-existent
husband but i don't necessarily think
george is gone for good later in the
episode the kids use a ouija board which
spells out
george is dead one of the kids here is
based off
emmett till a young boy who was lynched
in mississippi in 1955
after being accused of offending a white
woman in a grocery store
that explains why the ghost says he
won't have a fun time on his trip
but back to this george thing how would
the ghosts in the house know
george is dead unless he's somewhere
existing in the afterlife
or if it's george himself doing this
this would also fit in with dracula a
creature
that was simultaneously living while
dead so too will george become this type
of living but also dead entity
it's also important to note that
hippolyta buys this new copy of dracula
after she visits this mysterious room in
the mansion a room which has an
orary or mechanical model of a solar
system
well it can't be our solar system since
there are more than eight planets here
there also happens to be a telescope in
the background just like there's one in
george and hippolyta's bedroom i can't
help but think that someone may have
paid hippolyta a visit in this room
hence her buying a new copy of the book
someone definitely wanted her in there
as the door
opens on its own montrose has gone back
to the drink and noticed this quick shot
of the count of monte cristo a story
about a man escaping captivity just like
he did last episode there's also a
picture of his wife on the right the
same woman who cozied up to george in
his hallucination letty moves into the
house and fun easter egg the name of the
dog here
baldwin is named after james baldwin
whose speech on the american dream was
featured in episode 1. there's some
unresolved tension here between
letty and atticus he's planning to move
to florida and put everything that
happened in artem behind him that is
until a group of white supremacists give
them the shittiest welcome to the
neighborhood
ruby equates this to trumbull park a
real historical event that happened in
chicago in 1953
when a black family moved into a
predominantly white public housing
project their home was pelted with rocks
and fireworks and the police did nothing
to stop it
letty discovers a secret basement
beneath the boiler room we'll later find
out this is where that scientist
epstein conducted his experiments that's
why we'll see ghosts like babyhead over
here whose head transplant was one of
epstein's evil experiments
hippolyta talks about coping with the
loss of george and living with atticus
letty makes a comment
asking hippolyta if atticus reminds her
of george another slight hint that
atticus is
george's son if you haven't heard my
theory on that check out my episode 2
breakdown video what follows next is a
great example of how the music in this
episode lines up perfectly with the
action on screen
louis jordan's is you is or is you ain't
my baby plays while atticus
jealousy looks on as letty dances with
another man
i don't hurt anymore plays after letty
and atticus bang
and finally dorinda clark coles take it
back plays as letty smashes the cars
outside her home this results in letty
taken in by the police where she finds
out that the bodies of eight black men
and women were found in her home a few
years back a home built by horatio
winthrop one of the founding members of
the sons of adam his name can even be
found on the painting samuel showed off
in episode 2. horatio didn't like that
titus braithwight was the only one who
could decipher the book of names
so he decided to steal some of the pages
and make his own
cipher ultimately locking up these pages
in a booby trapped vault
you know that tunnel we see at the end
of the episode with dead bodies
some which look really old in it my
guess is that leads to this vault in
those pages hence why christina paid off
the realtor
and gave letty money in her mother's
name to get access to it christina seems
to be the ultimate puppet master here
pretty much confirming my thoughts that
she was responsible for her father's
death she knew he had invulnerability
but he'd have to take off that spell
during the ritual
and she also gave atticus that ring
which caused her father to turn to stone
letty accidentally blurts out that she
got the money for this house from her
mother's inheritance
something ruby her sister didn't know
anything about ruby is pissed and
rightly so ruby has been bailing letty
out of jail for years and sending her
money why would their mother give
letty money when letty wasn't the best
daughter heck letty didn't even come to
the funeral and to top it off
letty was being selfish and kept the
money to herself a trait she says letty
inherited from their mother letty does
more research on the house finding out
that a crooked cop was supplying epstein
with black folks to conduct experiments
on she finds newspaper articles of the
missing men and women and ominous photos
of their souls yearning to break free
their restless souls trapped in her
house with their killer she tells this
to atticus while also mentioning that
their little sexcapade was her first
time now i don't know about you guys but
i found this whole thing a bit
odd i don't think they'd make lydia a
virgin and show the blood unless there's
some significance for later episodes
for example we know how atticus comes
from titus braithwight's bloodline if he
gets letty pregnant he could be passing
on that bloodline which could have
significant ramifications for the story
lettie and atticus bring a witch doctor
to help free the spirits trapped within
the house
it's important to note here that leddy's
mother knew this voodoo practitioner so
we might see a link between letty's
ancestry
and magic they call upon mama oya the
spirit of death and rebirth who awakens
the restless spirits who
proceed to kill the invading white
supremacists leddy calls upon the
spirits using their real names to join
hands and banish
epstein allowing the spirits to
transform back to their normal selves
and pass on to the next life with the
spirits taken care of leti is
interviewed by a reporter who remarks on
how
selfless she is for creating a home for
those needing affordable housing
quite the contrast to what ruby thinks
of her the reporter asked if she knows
anything about the three missing white
guys who now sit
murdered in a secret level beneath the
home she says no
now i'm not sure if she's telling the
truth here or not letty was taking care
of the spirits while they were killed so
she either
found the bodies and moved them after or
someone else did we
just don't know yet finally we have
atticus's confrontation with christina
he wants her to stay away from his
family even points a gun at her
a particular note here is christina's
revelation that those who study the book
of names
are lucky if they can even manage one
spell in episode 1 we saw this car flip
in episode 2
a force field crash a car this seems to
be christina's power but whether or not
she has more is yet to be seen
she ends up giving him a business card
asking him to call her if he wants to
learn more about their family legacy if
i were atticus i'd hold on to that
that's it for today's video everyone
please make sure to like and subscribe
and leave a comment with your thoughts
and theories on the episode below
for more bad takes follow me on twitter
at thinkstoryyt
and until next time remember daddy loves
you very much